et coucou tout le monde ou est ce qu on
est aujourd'hui à les regarder dans un
endroit où j'ai mis de la poussière à la
loi mais ce monsieur gros quel bordel à
chaque fois c'est pas possible commencé
des vidéos etc un objectif sauver ça
c'est moi c'est tout moi ça comment ça
va eh bien j'espère que ça va changer le
regarder de quoi on parle aujourd'hui on
se parle de ça ça ce sont les nouveaux
samsung galaxy s 22 ans l'es22 il ya le
s bahn de plus qui est là bas may à
jesse qui bossent dessus coup d'essai ça
va ça va delarue a dit hier très heureux
donc ça c'est le f-22 il ya lui est
vingt-deux plus et puis l'es22 le
travail allait s 22 le trac je suis là
enfin je suis pas caché les s22 ultra
alors les s22 ultra on sent pas dans une
autre vidéo c'est un produit qui est
quand même différent raconte une autre
histoire pour un conte l'histoire de feu
la gamme note on raconte une histoire
d'un stylet on raconte une histoire de
la productivité on raconte l'histoire
d'un design vraiment différent au niveau
de la partie photo donc ça on s'en parle
différemment sur youtube d'ailleurs et
vidéo est arrivé tout de suite vous
pouvez y aller je vous mets un lien là
où un banc fabre à douma un lien et ça
c'est plutôt chouette parce qu'on aime
les liens ici et qu'on aime rester
connecté donc on se met ça de côté et on
en reparle un peu après on vient se
parler de cours ont bien se parler de ça
et ça c'est plutôt chouette vous savez
la gamme s et samsung c'est la gamme
photo vidéo donc là ils ont mis le
paquet on pourrait le dire comme ça au
niveau de la photo et de la vidéo ils
vont plus loin avec des capteurs qui
seront un peu plus grand au niveau des
esses 22h22 plus sony ou 2,22 traces
encore un peu plus grand mais on reparle
après dans une autre vidéo je vous ai
déjà expliqué et puis surtout vous avez
l'exil aux 2200 qui ira plus loin qu
aggraver en 4 nanomètres permettra
d'aller beaucoup plus haut et fort
beaucoup plus de choses capacités de
calcul accru de l'ia renforcer civile
gravure plus petit on va dire une plus
grosse autonomie bref plein de points
vraiment intéressant qu'on va venir voir
aujourd'hui dans cette vidéo pour parler
de quoi pourparlers n'ont pas pas de
pattes de boucherie papa boucherie on
parle des samsung galaxy s 22 e et s 22
plus et ça c'est vachement bien
c'est très très très chouette de pouvoir
parler de ces nouveaux samsung galaxy s
22e semaine de plus alors je vous ai pas
dans une autre vidéo des samsung galaxy
s 22 ultra c'est une autre vidéo je vous
mets le lien quelque part par là ou en
bas dans la description puis en même
temps ont été présentés des tablettes
samsung galaxy tab et suites et suit
plus est suite ultraplat première fois
une tablette en modèle ultra donc on
reparlera de l'ultra en reparlera tous
intérieurement mais c'est vrai que c'est
samsung nous nous surprend toujours
notamment avec la partie ultra et je
vous le dis ça c'est vachement cool mais
ils nous surprennent aussi avec tout ce
qui se passe au niveau de ces nouveaux
samsung galaxy s s 22 s 22 + et yasmine
de letra mais elle semaines de plus pour
quoi et bien parce qu'en fait on voit
une vraie segmentation cette fois ci
entre d'un côté regarde et venez voir je
voudrais vous faire des petits dessins
qu'on essayait de la voilà une petite
segmentation avec d'un côté et bien vous
avez les s 22 et es22 plus et puis vous
avez de l'autre côté le s 22 ultras qui
est vraiment un modèle totalement
différent et ça qui est intéressant
parce que l'année dernière ces modèles
là où même pas partir de 2020 parce
qu'on a vu à partir du s20 luttera s-21
ultra l as 22 on aille plus loin au
niveau du lustre art neuf des meilleurs
capteurs mais plus 2 mégapixels mais on
était sur un espèce de super s22 es22
plus là les gammes sont vraiment
différentes et on va vraiment que là on
se rapproche de la gamme note on est
vraiment sûr de la productivité et la
france et s 22 éval de plus on va plus
être sur des modèles un peu plus
mainstream un peu plus grand public où
on va venir chercher un excellent
smartphone pour toute la partie photo
bien évidemment s'en aller le plus loin
possible pour venir chercher un très bel
écran va revenir chercher de la
performance on va venir chercher
beaucoup de choses mais il ya quand même
quelques différences donc on va dire
s'attarder là dessus aujourd'hui sur cs
22 et s22 plus parce que ces deux
smartphones ils ont quand même quelques
différences ils sont intéressants ils
vont pas aller aussi loin que le f-22
une trame des fois on fera un petit peu
trop à voir si vous intéresse aussi
d'avoir un style tout ça sur mon avenir
réfléchir mais cs 22es 22 plus et bien
vaste et décortiqué déjà à commencer par
le poids une petite différence sur le s
22 on est ici sur 166 g versus 196 g un
poil plus lourd on s'en doutera il ya
une vraie belle symétrie qui a été fait
au niveau de la face avant vous avez
près la même dimension entre les bords
sur le haut et les bords sur le bas on
n'a pas ce qu'on appellera un grand on
tombe aussi on l'a pas donc ça c'est
plutôt bien de la même manière son corps
est légèrement bombé pour une bonne
prise en main et on est un peu plus plat
au dos par rapport à ce qu'on avait sur
les s 21 et s-21 plus de l'année
dernière et on va retrouver toujours un
capteur d'empreinte ultrasonique sous
l'écran pour venir déverrouiller très
facilement et puis sont dispo en quatre
couleurs alors je les ai noté la blanc
noir vert et rose comme ça il y en a
pour tout le monde je me doute que le
noir sera le modèle le plus vendu parce
que c'est un modèle plus consensuel mais
je pense que le ver a toutes ses chances
pour tous cas c'est celui que je viens
préféré moi ici alors ça me solari
toujours de très très beaux écrans et on
l'a vu l'année dernière avec le
dynamique amoled 2 x et si on garde la
même technologie d'écran donc dynamique
à molette 12x on a une différence
forcément contre c'est à deux écrans on
va être sur le s 22 / du 6,1 pouces qui
tu fais points quand tu veux toi si
j'avais eu le pouce tandis que sur le
modèle plus qui forcément plus grands
6,6 pouces c'est la différence
effectivement s'en doutera entre le plus
entre l'autre bon ok jusque là tout va
bien dans les deux cas on va être en
full hd plus il faut qu'on aille sur
l'ultra pour lors du pillage des plus on
a le vision de booster qui améliorera
l'image ok on a un taux de
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
hertz on sera entre 10 et 120 hertz taux
de rafraîchissement variable alors je
sais pas si je vais faire un petit
piqûre de rappel met au rafraîchissement
c'est le nombre d'image que vous avez
par seconde plus vous en avez et plus
l'image sera flynn et vous avez pas
besoin d'avoir du sang bears où le temps
a put lui vous allez avoir d'image par
second plus votre processeur va
travailler plus l'autonomie va diminuer
donc lorsque vous regardez un film une
série est bien du 25 images par seconde
suffira largement mais lorsque vous
allez jouer à des jeux gourmands du 120
images par secondes ça ira l'on montera
en 120 images par seconde on voit ici
c'est variable il le fera
automatiquement donc là vous êtes quand
même relativement tranquille et puis
vous avez également au taux
d'échantillonnage tactile de 240 r ça ça
apporte quoi sa porte parce que vous
allez venir jouer à des jeux ça va
permettre que une réaction plus rapide
par rapport au moment vous allez dire
toucher votre écran dont vous allez
avoir un ti gains de compétitivité par
rapport aux personnes contre qui vous
allez jouer ça serait en tout cas un peu
plus rapide c'est l'idée d'ailleurs bien
évidemment l'écran qui est là pour
lutter contre la lumière bleue mais ça
c'est le minimum qu'on attend
aujourd'hui des écrans de la qualité de
samsung parce que samsung vous avez
aussi une partie samsung display c'est
une énorme boîte sam sont display c'est
une entité à part de samsung electronics
qui fabrique les smartphones ils font
tous partie du groupe groupe samsung
samsung groupe vous n'allez pas
d'ailleurs dans une vidéo en vous
donnant tous les sucres et enfin
quasiment quelques jeux en tous cas de
samsung que je vous invite à aller voir
et puis votre écran même s'il est là
même si les belles qualités et bien il
faut quoi il faut venir le protéger
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui a
réalisé en partenariat avec mon
partenaire rhino schild alors soyons
clairs on va pas se mentir c'est
important de venir protéger son
smartphone pour quoi et bien parce que
s'il tombe pour la moins deux
déconvenues vous serez content d'avoir
une coque de protection devenir le
protéger et croyez moi c'est super
important j'ai déjà pété le dos d'un
smartphone ya pas si longtemps que ça
dérange pas parce que je testais ça m'a
fait un peu râler et au niveau de
l'écran c'est pareil déjà fait tomber
lorsque j'étais en vacances sur des
rochers ça m'a pété la vendons bref ça
peut arriver et il est quand même bien
de rien le protégé d'autant plus que
chez rhinochill vous avez des corps qui
sont très très très jolie alors regardez
je vous montre déjà il nous les affiches
là les samsung galaxy s 22 qui sont au
catalogue alors au moment à laquelle je
tourne cette vidéo les smartphones n'ont
pas été officialisés donc si vous allez
sur cette partie là sur leur site et
bien vous ne verrez pas grand chose mais
à partir du moment où vous regardez
cette vidéo ça veut dire que et bien ils
sont officialisées donc vous aurez
toutes les infos directement sur leur
site alors on va parler de
personnalisation parce que c'est le truc
qui est vachement intéressant déjà vous
avez des coques de tous les côtés vous y
retrouvez sur votre smartphone android
et bien des solides suite ce sont des
coques de protection pour l'arrière du
smartphone mais vous avez également des
protections au niveau de l'écran vous
avez des protections en vitre trempé
vous avez des câbles et puis si vous
avez un autre smartphone d'une autre
marque et bien vous avez des crashs gare
pour apple par exemple vous avez les
mots d'eric vous avez également des
coques pour les airs poggia également
des accessoires pour les appels watch
fait un bref et puis applicables de tous
les côtés donc ça c'est vachement bien
et on peut surtout venir les
personnaliser alors autant il ya des
design qui sont faits par inochi qu'ils
sont sympas pour moi ce qui me fait
craquer ici eh bien ce sont les
collaborations garder spider man vous
avez snoopy vous avez quoi ça c'est du
lilo et stitch à ces parcs disney
classiques disney classics c'est dur à
dire via la nba avec les lakers et du
star wars bref note tous les côtés je
suis hyper hyper hyper canon alors gardé
les meilleures bandes c'est quoi ces
mini ça c'est que le rugby français et
puis il y en a pour tout le monde vous
avez van gogh museum star wars one piece
disney classique je voulais montrer ya
marvel dragon ball france rugby disney
pixar mickey qui a également la halle
attaques des titans harry potter g2
esport mandaloriennes j'adore les gens
râlent en ce moment le livre de boba
fett sur dix n'est plus et hyper canon
batman batman batman qui va arriver
bientôt s'associent vachement cool
dragon ball z la nasa snoopy league of
legends je vous en passe il y en a des
tonnes regarder y en a vraiment vraiment
d'étoles donc vous allez bien trouver
ici votre bonheur fairy tail fabre et
voilà on avance donc là c'est vachement
cool donc si vous voulez dire protéger
votre smartphone dans les meilleures
conditions et bien vous avez en plus le
code greu 22 vous allez voir 5% de
remise pour dire protéger vos
smartphones dans les meilleures
conditions ça c'est vachement bien merci
qui merci rhinochill c'est une bonne
nouvelle et une fois de plus le lien
juste en bas dans la description un très
bon smartphone aussi c'est quoi évincé
de lo'jo cellule audio de bonne qualité
ici on va dans des haut-parleurs stéréo
du bluetooth on parle de brefs hausse
grâce à aussi lors du test donc venez
vous abonner ce n'est pas déjà fait
comme ça on verra ensemble et on testera
ensemble ces nouveaux samsung galaxy s
22 et s22 plus et puis la performance la
performance massa c'est vachement cool
regarder samsung a annoncé l'exynos 2200
alors souvent je me dis ben tiens les
exils aussi son bien mais vont pas aussi
loin que les simples règles clairement
sauf que là est un partenariat avec amd
amd qui a travaillé sur le gpu dont sur
toute la partie graphique au niveau
l'exynos 2200 et pourquoi est ce que
tout ça vachement intéressant mais ça
veut dire que pour le gaming ils vont
aller vachement plus loin donc on le
voit déjà on a un taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 240 m bon ok vous me direz
c'est normal jour du haut de gamme ça
fonctionne mais l'art j'ai hâte de le
tester à de voir si vraiment il va tenir
ses promesses en terme de performance
entre de gainey à mon avis ça va être
vraiment un des gros gros gros point
fort et peut-être que ce sera un point
de bascule par rapport à ce qu'on avait
chez qualcomm les années précédentes au
niveau des stands dragonne y avait
toujours un petit déséquilibre parce que
je vous refais un peu l'histoire lorsque
on sait smartphone sans que les nouveaux
samsung galaxy s vous avez pour l'europe
et pour une partie du monde grosse
partie du monde isabelle exynos et puis
pour le nord amérique canada états unis
puis une partie de l'asie vous avez des
processeurs de qualcomm avoir ici avec
l'exil aux 2200 s'envole la pâté ou pas
voilà je pense que ça peut envoyer le
steak ça peut être intéressant alors
autre différence qu'on va venir regarder
ici et bien en fait c'est que vous allez
avoir sur le f-22 une batterie de 3700
milliampères heures au quai tandis que
sur les ultras vous êtes un peu plus
4500 milliampères heures alors on se
dira ok ça ça fonctionne on a un écran
qui est un peu plus grand donc il faut
un peu plus de 1000 urbain mais ça veut
aussi dire ce qui est quand même un
delta de 800 millions t1 entre les deux
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
potentiellement ici on devrait avoir une
meilleure autonomie sens le verra
également lors du test ultérieurement
layar tout cas savoir également c'est
que sans notre s22 vous avez un bloc de
charges alors qu'il n'est pas inclus
attention faut venir l'acheter en plus
mais on peut venir charger macsquant 25
watts tandis que sur le f-22 plus vous
pouvez bien chargé en max jusqu'à 45
watts il ya une différence qu'elle a
aussi un ils sont dit ok sur votre s 22
vous venir charger quand même un peu
plus lentement comme ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière attention c'est déjà
rapide du 25 watts mais on vient pas
doublé mais presque sur le s 22 plus en
45 en attendant les deux cas vous venir
changé en 15 watts sans fil ok mais
voyez ils ont voulu également marquer la
différence entre ces deux modèles bon
dans l'idée pourquoi pas et puis on
tourne et c'est sur quoi sur manuel 4.1
basé sur un android 12 de donner des
astuces sur un nuage katia pas longtemps
donc vous invite à bien voir ma vidéo
pour tout savoir pour utiliser vos
smartphones de samsung dans les
meilleures conditions lors la gamme s
c'est quoi la gamme s c'est également
toute une grosse partie photo vidéo
c'est l'adn de la gamme s on voit
qu'avec le ultra on a rajouté la partie
productivité mais ici c'est la partie
photo vidéo soyons clair donc on a
exactement la même chose entre le galaxy
s 22 et le s 22 plus exactement la même
chose en grand-angle de 50 méga pixels
avec autofocus dual pixels une
stabilisation optique et on ouvre ici à
f 1.8 ok ok ok ok très bien on va venir
faire ce qu'on appelle du pixel baning
salies regrouper plusieurs pixels pour
le mettre en un seuil même pixels espèce
de grand pixels notamment pour les
photos en faible luminosité et si vous
avez plus celle qui montre un peu plus
large ici on est à 2 micromètres versus
2 4 micromètres sur le ultra il ya un
poil plus loin on s'en doutera on a en
plus ce qu'on appellera un nouvel allié
spi au travers de cet exil hausse je
vous ai marqué ici l'exynos 2200 la
liasse puis c'est quoi c'est le
processeur d'image permettra d'aller
plus loin en terme de calcul donc tout
ce qui va être photo/vidéo nuit on va
aller plus loin même lé en plein jour un
très clairement même si en plein jour
brad le général le boulot était
relativement bien fait donc on verra ça
lors du test à noter que vous avez
également un ultra grand-angle de 12
mégapixels couvre f 2.2 avec un champ de
vision de 120 degrés puis vous avez un
tel objectif avec un zoom optique x 3 je
dis bien optique x 3 cuves rêve 2.4 et
une caméra de sa fille de 10 mégapixels
pu voir f 2.2 donc qu'est ce que ça nous
montre situations les promesses et bien
cette photo vidéo nuit vidéo nuit sommes
pas aussi être assez intéressant on
regardera tout ça il va y avoir plein de
nouveaux modes du portrait décidé ça
c'est vraiment logiciel mais est ce qui
est intéressant c'est comme on a un
processeur qui est gravé en 4 nanomètres
ça permettra ici de quoi et bien d'aller
vachement plus loin parce qu'on va avoir
une meilleure autonomie parce qu'on aura
une meilleure puissance de calcul parce
qu'on voit que le gaming ici est
vraiment mis à l'avant on voit que la
performance va être mis à l'amendé est
intéressant et je pense que les photos
vont être sublimées par rapport à ce
qu'on avait les années précédentes et
notamment au niveau des seins progrès 6
aces matériel 21 puis on le verra un peu
plus tard qu'est ce qu'il ya également
comme autre point qui est intéressant à
bien c'est qu'ici vous avez du wifi si
ce bon ok marche des smartphones qui
sont également certifiés résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière ip68 c'est le
grand minimum combien attendre sur
l'ultra haut de gamme chez samsung
aujourd'hui alors rien de ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le smn de plus est
le seul à avoir de l' ultra wide band
alors à quoi sert l ultra wide band et
bien ça vous sert sur une distance très
courte venir notamment et on l'a vu au
travers des smart tags et smart tags
plus à venir trouver vos objets et c'est
marrant que l' ultra wide band il est mû
uniquement sur le s 22 plus et pas sur
le s 22 c'est très bizarre parce que
même le f-22 hurler sur un smartphone
très haut de gamme on n'est pas sûr du
milieu de gamme on n'est pas sur une
gamme hp samsung on n'est pas sûr en est
21è phoques qui est très cool mais on
l'a que sur le f 22 je me demande ça me
saoule pourquoi vous avez fait ça
pourquoi ce choix pourquoi ne pas
l'intégrer sur le s 22 ultra wide band
il ya un non sens en fait on sait qu'il
ya quelques mois vous avez sorti bien
des smart tags et smart tags plus moi je
pense aux smart avec +1 je me dis tiens
j'ai un smart tags plus je trouvais mes
objets à proximité grâce à l' ultra wide
band va être extrêmement précis je vais
savoir s'il est là ou s'il est là si les
peurs qu'ils soient en coin ici vous un
oreiller et voilà je comprends pas ça
c'est pour moi c'est un non sens donc ça
va vraiment venir jouer en faveur du s
bahn de plus si vous allez dans
l'écosystème samsung si vous voulez
plein d'objets connectés de samsung si
vous voulez un smart tags plus pour nous
retrouver vos clés facilement retrouver
votre portefeuille que vous perdez s22
plus simple la question pour moi elle se
pose absolument pas s 22 plan farr bien
évidemment on a dû en effet pour le
moins dématérialisée puis cette fois ci
on a pas d'écouteurs pas d'écouteurs
dans la boîte alors je voulais déjà dit
dans la vidéo s 22 ultra je sais pas si
vous l'avez regardé avant celle ci si
c'est pas le cas je vous explique en
fait depuis des années en france les
constructeurs doivent obligatoirement
mettre des écouteurs filaires dans leur
boîte pour minimiser le risque
d'exposition aux ondes pour le
consommateur comme ça le smartphone est
un peu plus loin n'est pas plaquer
contre nos visages et ça c'est cool sauf
qu'aujourd'hui pour des questions
d'environnement tout ça aussi très très
bien tension l'environnement plus plus
plus plus son attention je ne mets pas
du tout ça dans la balance mais on dit
on l'aimé plus on l'aimé plus parce que
on part du principe que des gens des
peut-être déjà des écouteurs ok mais si
des gens n'avaient plus d'écouteurs si
les écouteurs été abîmée si c'était
l'occasion de voir nouveaux écouteurs
bas on aura plus bas donc sachez qu'ici
vous allez acheter ses smartphones
samsung galaxy s 21 samsung galaxy s 22e
semaine de plus eh bien vous n'aurez pas
d'écouteurs filaire à l'intérieur pour
après vous allez voir que c'est
intéressant parce que samsung vous offre
des bugs pro et je vous en parle
justement tout de suite on va y aller
mardi parce que vous avez des offres de
pré lancement alors attendez je vous
mets ça ou je vous mets ça nul pas vous
avez j'ai plus de place en mai feuilles
donc entendu nouvelles feuilles
pas se laisser mourir de faim quand même
fait regarder sur le f 22 vous avez une
config est intéressante c'est la 8 +128
ou là vous êtes à 859 euros autant vous
dire c'est le même tarif qu'on avait
l'année dernière et vous avez également
un autre tarif qui est plutôt que ça sur
le s 22 plus la ctaq tac tac tac tac
vous avez également 1,8 +128 et vous
avez aussi 1,8 plus de 156 à regarder il
ya un truc intéressant et je sais pas si
vous avez regardé ma vidéo une fois de
plus sur les ultras c'est que sur
l'ultra avec le 256 vous passez en 12
giga là vous êtes 8 giga d'un bon
viendra gagner en fluidité sur l'ultra
non cellule tracé le plus haut de gamme
il faut bien faire des différences dans
les gammes là vous êtes à 1059 euros on
passe la barre des 1000 euros mais sur
du plus aujourd'hui on s'y attend et il
n'y a pas grande surprise est là sur le
8 plus de 156 vous êtes à 1159 euros
donc on rajoute non je dis n'importe
quoi on est ici à 1109 euros envoyés
pour 50 euros de plus vous venez doublez
votre stockage en plus de ça et c'est ça
qui est intéressant pour moi c'est à
dire que c'est pour ça que je trouve que
cette config là elle est intéressante
c'est dire que sur le f-22 on dirait 828
ça ne va pas mal mais dès lors qu'on
veut aller sur le s20 de plus qui va
paraître vraiment intéressant et bien
c'est le 8 256 alors effectivement ça
reste beaucoup d'argent attention je
vous dis pas que 50 euros c'est pas
beaucoup d'argent 50 euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent mais pour 50 euros de
plus vous doublez votre stockage et puis
en rond on va dire aujourd'hui quelles
sont vraiment les grosses différences
que vous allez avoir entre le f-22 et le
f-22 plus bas déjà c'est alors le poids
ça fait partie de l'équation 168 ram
versus d'à côté 196 g bon ok il ya une
petite différence à les minimes la
taille de l'écran 6,1 pouces versus 6,6
pouces ok vous avez une batterie 3700
milliampères heures versus 4500 millions
perreur bon ok mais surtout ici eh bien
vous avez de l'ultra wideband que vous
n'avez pas ici est ok ça me paraît fou
et puis c'est tout ce sont vraiment les
différences que vous avez que
j'identifie rien dire et peut-être
d'autres mais je sais pas identifié même
au niveau du dos du smartphone j'ai pas
vu de différence je me suis peut-être
pas fait gaffe mais de toute façon comme
il faut venir le protégé bon c'est pas
vraiment ça qui va venir à changer
l'histoire ah si la recharge excusez moi
la recharge là vous venez vont charger
en 25 watts là vous venez vont charger
ou 45 watts et puis je vous le dis vous
avez également les différences de prix
allant de 859 euros sur la version 128
et là on est à mille 59 euros sur la
version 128 je vous conseille la version
256 pour 50 euros là je peux y arriver
pour 50 euros plus au moins ici vous
fois plus de stockage pour 50 euros plus
alors on se dira vers quel smartphone
venir se diriger aujourd'hui tout en
sachant qu'on a la même proposition en
photo la même proposition en vidéo on a
dit des monnaies différentes en termes
d'écrans ok ok ok bon moi mon coeur
viendrait me dire puisque tu mets de
l'argent alors il ya quand même une
grosse différence intentions entre 859
emile 109 euros clairement il ya
beaucoup d'argent mais si vous en avez
les moyens je vous dirais aujourd'hui
sur la partie connectivité d'aller sur
le plus pourquoi ben parce que il ya un
truc qui est vachement intéressant et
sur la notion d'écosystème une fois de
plus c'est ça qui est intéressant
l'ultra wideband alors refroidir ces
gadgets est ce que je veux dire souvent
l'utiliser du travail bande n'ont pas
tous les jours mais le jour où on aurait
besoin vous serez bien content de le
trouver voilà cc marco ah parce que trop
vachement intéressant c'est que sur le s
22 et bien vous habitez à fait quand
même extrêmement bien positionné par
rapport à la concurrence et si vous
regardez par rapport au prix de
lancement du s21 effet il ya quelques
semaines et ben on reste extrêmement
bien positionné leurs j'imagine que tous
les tarifs vont un petit peu évoluer les
tarifs ds21 vont forcément diminuer le s
motor en effet pas je pense aussi
mécaniquement diminué mais tout ça je
vous invite à débattre sur le site de
samsung d'ailleurs ses smartphones vous
intéresse allez jeter un petit coup
d'oeil en bas sur le site de samsung et
puis un dernier point qui est vachement
intéressant c'est surtout ce qui va être
offre de lancement alors déjà samsung
vous offre des galaxies hunt pro et ça
c'est cool et ça c'est vachement bien
rare d'autant plus que vous avez pas aux
écouteurs filaires donc vous avez au
galaxy pro offert et en plus de ça vous
avez 100 euros de plus par rapport à la
valeur de reprise de votre ancien
smartphone donc si vous vous dites
maintien j'en sais rien moi j'ai ensuite
que je veux faire reprendre et on vous
le reprendre un certain prix et ils vont
rajouter 100 euros sur la table histoire
que vous soyez heureux et ça se fera
mais gagner un peu d'argent donc si vous
partez sur un ace 22 à 859 euros et
seront plus y rajoute et bien j'en sais
rien moi c'est 100 euros ça vous le
tombe à 759 euros plat 759 euros ici vos
smartphones et vous le reprenez 300
euros par garde et il vous reste 459
euros à débourser pour avoir un nouveau
samsung galaxy s 22 ans à ses canons
achement bien non allez avoue d'ailleurs
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez et
puis surtout dites moi ce que vous
voulez qu'on regarde ce que vous voulez
qu'on teste de quelle manière vous
voulez qu'on les têtes vous marquez
toutes vos questions en bas aussi aux
commentaires et puis j'y répondrai lors
des phases de telles que ça va être
vachement cool et puis si vous avez des
onze villes des suggestions les
commentaires sont là pour ça d'ici là je
vous embrasse le gros bisous beaucoup
d'amour prenez soin de vous et qui a
très vite on continue à parler à de
samsung mais aussi de pas notre marque
parce que là vous voyez peut-être pas
mais il ya plein de choses qui arrivent
il ya plein de nouveautés qui commencent
à arriver ça se relance tout doucement
ça va être vachement bien voilà des
bisous de l'amour pour les sens et vous
très bientôt entendre à ce forfait
enfants forts
[Musique]